foreign
on this Friday night Fiona comes
crashing into Canada
anxiety in the Atlantic as people stock
up on supplies and braced for impact my
main concern is how long it's going to
last for the historic post-tropical
storm set to Roar ashore in just hours a
gruesome report on Russian war crimes in
Ukraine relatives were forced to witness
the crimes the findings from U.N
investigators as the Kremlin holds Sham
referendums in russian-occupied areas
cracking down on descent and cutting off
the internet all of us are very
concerned fears over what Iran will do
next to silence feminists plus serving
up one last match tennis great Roger
Federer retires his racket tonight
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight Jeff Semple good
evening and thank you for joining us
people in Atlanta Canada are bracing for
one of the worst storms this country has
ever seen here's a snapshot of what's
coming this dramatic drone video shows
Wild Waves in the Atlantic Ocean as
hurricane Fiona slammed into Bermuda now
that hurricane is poised to become a
powerful post-tropical storm by the time
it crashes into Canada's Coast overnight
let's go straight to our Ross Lord now
who is in Port Hastings for us in Nova
Scotia tonight so Ross how are looking
how are things looking there now
well Jeff the rain is well underway the
wind only now beginning to pick up some
of the Waves kicking Up On the Rocks
here at the cancel Causeway at or near
where forecasters say Fiona will make
landfall in just a few hours the
causeway is the connection between Cape
Breton and the mainland and it's a key
indicator because how well it endures
Fiona will be a good indication of the
storm's impact
that this could potentially be one of
the worst storms that Canada's Coast has
ever seen when it comes to bad weather
Cape bretoners don't scare easily they'd
rather joke about loading up on snack
food well I use this one as an excuse to
get storm chips a little anxious I guess
but she admits in the hours before
Fiona's arrival it's hard to keep fear
at Bay store shelves are running low on
essential supplies like canned goods
camp stoves and lanterns
people loading up for a struggle with
warnings Fiona's extreme wind and
torrential rain could cause widespread
damage and power outages throughout
Atlantic Canada for days or even weeks
my main concern is how long it's going
to last for that's the biggest thing so
I have a tendency to go with my
priorities of course with this water and
so on and and things that I can actually
cook and because I'm going to have
limited electricity of course some
meteorologists foresee Fiona making
landfall as a post-tropical storm but
with the impact of a category 2
hurricane like the devastating hurricane
wanded 19 years ago in terms of the
storm's size it's certainly bigger than
one uh was when one made landfall in
2003 in terms of Dorian it's it's
comparable in terms of its size but it
is it's stronger than Dorian was back in
2019 in Nova Scotia a province wide
emergency alert told people to avoid the
coastline and rivers a message many seem
to be heating we're really hunkered down
anything that was outside that could
possibly be moved is packed away in the
garage we got some food cooked ahead of
time so we won't be hungry for the next
72 hours it's what Michelle McDonald
can't control that bothers her like what
will happen to these trees and the trees
make me nervous because they're hanging
over the power lines and they're older
trees and we lost quite a few during
Dorian and some of the houses here lost
power for five days because of it
emergency planners including power
utilities have been preparing all week
for Fiona's arrival doing table top
exercises making sure we're ready for a
command center if need be making sure
we're ready for Comfort centers if need
be
foreign
we saw a stream of trucks holding uh
power line repair Crews coming into Port
Hawkesbury area this evening some of the
hundreds of Crews that have been put on
standby for what forecasters expect to
be a grueling weekend in Atlanta Canada
and in eastern Quebec Jeff all right
Ross Lord and Port Hastings Nova Scotia
take care thanks Ross and for more on
what to expect from this storm let's
bring in Global's chief meteorologist
Anthony fernell he joins us now from
Lewisburg on Cape Breton Island in Nova
Scotia essentially the edge of the
Atlantic so Anthony what's it like where
you are right now
well we may not get the center of the
storm passing directly overhead but
what's going to happen tonight are
likely some of the worst winds waves and
surge that Fiona has to offer and that
really has residents around here in Cape
Breton quite concerned this time around
versus some of the prior hurricanes like
Dorian like Juan that may be spared this
region a little bit more than others so
the winds have been picking up we're
getting these outer bands that are now
moving in each time it rains again the
winds are a little bit stronger and
really the worst of it's going to be
after midnight tonight through the
morning hours tomorrow that surge
coinciding with high tide in the morning
that's a big concern one to maybe two
meters and then the waves incredible
waves of 10 to as much as 15 meters just
off the coast causing erosion and
possibly some damage and washed out
roads as well the wind
150 160 kilometer per hour in gusts and
this is going to extend maybe not to
that level but 100 plus kilometer per
hour winds for much of the province
including Halifax into New Brunswick as
well so it's a massive massive storm and
a record breaker as far as intensity
goes Jeff wow some tense hours ahead so
and what can you tell us Anthony about
exactly where Fiona is headed and the
punch that she's expected to pack
well it's hard to believe that just last
night that's when the hurricane was
making its closest approach to Bermuda
and now later tonight it'll be directly
overhead here so once it arrives it's
slowing down so those hurricane Force
gusts are going to be around for six to
12 hours for Cape Breton and for parts
of the Mainland same thing with Pei
which is going to feel it especially
those North Shore Beaches are going to
just take a beating and then it moves
into the Gulf of Saint Lawrence
Madeleine the western part of
Newfoundland feeling the hurricane as
well weakening as it does so it gets
away from the warm Waters it loses that
energy source but this is going to be a
long weekend for residents around here
Jeff all right Global News meteorologist
Anthony fernell in Lewisburg Nova Scotia
stay safe thanks Anthony
what's up
and that extreme weather on the East
Coast comes just as young people took to
the streets across Canada today part of
an international day of climate action
to highlight the devastating impacts of
global warming while also demanding more
aid for poorer countries that are
struggling to cope climate protests were
held in Vancouver Kingston Ontario and
in Quebec
[Applause]
and thousands of young people also
rallied at New Zealand's Parliament
today as part of that Global day of
climate action while in South Korea's
capital students skipped school for
their Fridays for future rally 11 people
there were killed just last month after
a devastating rainstorm and 22 000
people rallied in Berlin today one of
250 German cities organizing events
active as their calling for an end to
fossil fuels and expansion of renewable
energy
and another story we're tracking in
Atlantic Canada tonight the public
portion of the inquiry into the worst
mass shooting in modern Canadian history
has finally drawn to a close the
hearings of the 2020 Nova Scotia
Massacre spanned seven months and
included more than 200 Witnesses and
thousands of documents well on this
final day the three Commissioners
leading the investigation shared their
thoughts ahead of their final report
that's expected early next year as
Graham Benjamin explains the victim's
families hope it will lead to
long-lasting change
we must together take action to build
safer communities commissioner Michael
McDonald
ire into the April April T20 Nova Scotia
mass shooting finally comes to an end we
took on this responsibility to ensure
that all those whose lives
have been taken will not
have been in vain the mass casualty
commission has been trying to discover
exactly what happened during a 13-hour
period on April 18th and 19th 2020 when
a denturists disguised as a police
officer killed 22 people in several
rural Nova Scotia communities since
February 22nd witness after witness has
taken the stand now the Commissioners
must create a final report one that
potentially includes recommendations to
ensure a tragedy of this magnitude never
happens again the final report will be
comprehensive
it needs to be both Broad and deep in
order to fill our mandate but getting to
this point has been difficult faith in
the process has dwindled day by day with
special accommodations being given to
key RCMP decision makers for its part
the Department of Justice asserting that
the accommodations followed the
commission's trauma-informed Mandate and
that officers responded to the shooting
the best they could with the resources
available no response to a critical
incident of this magnitude could be
perfect but when this crisis hit
the RCMP showed up lawyers representing
families of the victims say
recommendations are not enough if they
don't lead to real action we're going to
see recommendations that are not just
good on paper but that will you know
meaningfully change the public safety
for a positive way the final report is
scheduled to be released to the public
by March 31st 2023 at the latest Graham
Benjamin Global News Halifax
after a nearly year-long vacancy Canada
has finally appointed its new ambassador
to China Jennifer May is a 30-year
veteran Diplomat whose work has spanned
three continents most recently May
served as Canadian ambassador to Brazil
she's also the first woman to name to
the Post in Beijing the Canadian Prime
Minister tweeted about May's appointment
as Canada's ambassador to China shall
manage this important bilateral
relationship and Advance Canadian
interests
the kremlins so-called referendums are
now underway in four Russian occupied
regions of Ukraine voters there are
being asked if they want to leave
Ukraine and join the Russian Federation
thousands of Russians took to the
streets to show their support but in
Kiev and across the West that vote is
being widely condemned as a sham
there are fears the results will be used
as a pretext for President Putin to
escalate his aggression Meanwhile we're
also learning more disturbing details
about a United Nations inquiry that
found Russia carried out a quote large
number of war crimes in those voting
regions Jackson prosco has the details
in four occupied regions of Ukraine
there is only one question on the ballot
yes or no to joining Russia I am ready
to vote says this woman I wish we had
support from Russia much earlier the
so-called referendum is happening under
the long shadow of Russian violence and
oppression in a region where at least
half the population has fled
I am against the referendum she says I
think that my town and my region fully
belong to Ukraine Ukraine and the West
have decried the vote as a sham warning
the predetermined result will be a
pretext for Russia to take more drastic
military measures when that's complete
we can expect President Putin will claim
any Ukrainian effort to liberate this
land as an attack on so-called Russian
territory an independent U.N commission
concludes Russia has already committed
extensive war crimes in the regions
including the rape and torture of
children we have struck by the large
number of executions in the areas that
we visited
Vladimir Putin has also threatened the
use of nuclear weapons
his decision to call up 300 000
reservists has rattled Russia buses were
seen taking men away to fight after
tearful goodbyes to their families at
the border with neighboring Finland
young Russian men rushed to flee when
Putin has his pitch
I just packed my bag and directly go to
Finland I definitely don't want to be uh
like drafted around this kind of kind of
thing that that's for sure back in the
occupied regions voting will run until
Tuesday a simple formality before Russia
makes the inevitable move to Annex more
of Ukraine's territory
Jackson prosco Global News
Iran deals with dissent coming up the
regime grapples with its most serious
challenge in years plus flood ravaged
Pakistan scrambles to stop the spread of
disease
welcome back tensions are escalating in
Iran between protesters and the
government it's been one week since 22
year old Masa amini died after being
detained by the country's so-called
morality police well today the U.S gave
the green light to expand internet
services to Iranians cut off by the
state and as Heather York's West
explains with growing protests there's
also mounting concern over how Iran's
regime will respond
in this video shot by the Iraqi news
agency Riddell shots can be heard over
protests in the city of sardasht
[Applause]
Mueller seen in the western city of
armia though it's been a week since the
death of 22 year old Masa amini sparked
outrage across the country video of the
protests have become harder for the
world to see internet is super slowed
down two major application WhatsApp and
Instagram are shut down it's something
Iranians have witnessed their government
do before and what it signals is
chilling all of us are very concerned
about what's going in Iran because we
had a very bad experience with
internet shot down and when the internet
is caught it means that you're gonna
start a mass meter in 2019 amidst
widespread protests over fuel prices the
government shut down internet access for
four days while implementing a brutal
Crackdown on the streets Amnesty
International estimates more than 300
people were killed the U.S Secretary of
State wrote Friday we took action today
to advance internet freedom for the
Iranian people issuing a general license
to provide them greater access to
digital Communications a spokesperson
for the U.N Secretary General also
appealed for calm we call in security
forces from to refrain from using
unnecessary and disproportionate force
and appeal to all uh to exercise
restraint to avoid further escalation
according to Iranian State television
more than two dozen protesters and
police have been killed in the last week
on Friday a state organized counter
demonstration was held with Marchers
calling for the execution of protesters
after years of growing unrest this may
become Iran's moment of Reckoning
Heather urich's West Global News
in flood ravaged Pakistan thousands of
additional doctors are being deployed to
the country's hardest hit province in an
effort to slow the rapid spread of
diseases tearing through shelters and
makeshift camps
eighteen thousand doctors and nearly 38
000 paramedics are already treating
survivors in sin Province where hundreds
of thousands of people displaced by the
devastating floods are now living in the
open washing drinking and living around
stagnant water which is leading to
widespread cases of malaria typhoid and
Dengue Fever Health authorities say
malaria has already killed more than 300
people there and in the past week has
infected some 44 thousand
next Global News drills down on Canada's
energy dilemma
unlocking Canada's energy wealth helping
European allies starved of oil and gas
while also cutting greenhouse gas
emissions is a tall order but it may not
be impossible in a one-hour special
tonight Global News drills down on the
role indigenous communities might play
and how energy entrepreneurs are finding
new opportunities David Aiken looks at
the political will and Emissions targets
that may be needed to get Canadian
natural gas to Europe David
well Jeff let's look at two angles on
this issue of getting natural gas to
Europe first to Brad wall who of course
spent a decade as Saskatchewan's Premier
he's a veteran of fed Prof meetings and
since he's out of politics these days he
can speak a little more freely so I
visited wall earlier this summer near
his home in Southwest Saskatchewan where
he spends a lot of time on his horse
these days learning to be a cowboy so
after a session of roping and branding
calves we talked about how the energy
and climate discussion in Canada changed
with Russia's invasion of Ukraine Canada
can perhaps help on the LNG front in
Europe if they want to get off of
Russian Supply but in order for us to do
that we got to be able to get it to Port
but Quebec has long opposed any new
pipeline that would take Western gas to
an Atlantic Port wall believes it is the
premiers themselves who should lead the
discussion on that issue if I think
Quebec would bristle in most provinces
would at the notion of a federal
government saying all right this
pipeline is happening and we're going to
put the full weight of the federal
government behind it
I think the answer has got to be the
premiers now what to do about greenhouse
gas emissions polls have consistently
shown that Canadians want their country
to be a green good guy if you will so
for this question I went to Montreal to
talk to Chris Reagan an economist at
McGill University who is an advocate of
much more aggressive climate policy but
he says if Canadian natural gas could
get to Europe it could displace dirty
coal and oil there so in a global sense
this will reduce emissions this is a
good idea but in Canada it will increase
emissions because we will burn a pile of
natural gas to run the compressors to
liquefy that LNG and so we may blow past
our targets and then you say maybe we
don't have the right domestic Target for
a world that has these Ambitions and has
these energy security issues so these
are just a couple of the ideas Jeff that
we will explore in our special tonight
as we try to figure out if Canada can
indeed be an energy superpower while
still meeting its climate change
commitments
David Aiken in Ottawa thanks David and
you can watch landlocked Canada's energy
dilemma at nine Eastern and Pacific 10
mountain right here on global and that
is global national for this Friday night
I'm Jeff Semple tonight's your Canada is
this pronghorn antelope near Lancer
Saskatchewan thanks for watching Farah
Nasser will be at the anchor desk with
you tomorrow have a great night
[Music]